le contexte est explosif et anthony
blinken le cerf le secrétaire d'état
américain à une mission trouver une
solution diplomatique à la crise en
ukraine la pire entre les occidentaux et
la russie depuis la fin de la guerre
froide
la russie refusent toujours de retirer
les cent mille soldats qu'elle a
déployés à la frontière avec l'ukraine
et la biélorussie qui est elle aussi
frontalière de l'ukraine annonce
l'arrivée d'un nombre indéterminé de
soldats russes sur son sol pour des
exercices de préparation au combat
et du côté du pentagone
le discours est tout aussi tendue
challenger oil and gas corp et car la
russie considère toujours qu'elle est
menacée sur son flanc ouest moscou
réclame un accord officiel qui
stipulerait que l'ukraine ne devienne
jamais membre de l'otan et que
l'alliance atlantique se retire des pays
balte
qu'à cuba mission
de
l'otan une nouvelle fois déclaré que le
risque de conflits en ukraine était réel
et a renouvelé son soutien à kiev la
suède elle et c'est très inhabituel a
déployé l'armée sur la côte baltique une
réponse selon les forces militaires
suédoise à l'activité russe dans la
région